Hi I'm Andy, and this Sarah, and she would speak for
herself, if she weren't totally engrossed in this game of 2048.
>> Sorry, guys.
>> And if you've never played it, it's incredibly addictive, and
it's open source, which means in about 30 minutes,
you can have your entirely own version of this game.
Sara, do you want to pause for a second and show them the thing you made?
>> Sure.
>> So ,we made a version of the game using US presidents.
You can really do anything, and it doesn't take very long.
If you're a novice programmer or have no programming experience you can,
in ten minutes, understand how, at a very high level, this code works.
That's pretty cool and
if this sounds interesting, can't wait to see you in class.